[Music]
okay now 5 55 on your friday morning
truck and truck traffic and turn signals
where the 95 meets the northern 215
beltway come on let's go
centennial bowling
so a viewer who calls herself northwest
mom writes hey can you please help me
understand why the turn signal at the
exit from
u.s 95 south to anne road has only one
left turn lane but the exit from north
95 at ann road has two left turn lanes
she continues a lot of construction
trucks that exit southbound
that results in cars sitting through
multiple lights some drivers turning
left
out of the middle lane that's designed
to go straight back onto the freeway she
says
somebody's going to get into a serious
crash you know what that sounds
frustrating and definitely dangerous mom
the nevada department of
transportation's tony ilya says
a lot of that truck traffic probably is
connected to the ongoing work for the
centennial bulls final phase but he adds
although there are no current plans to
alter that specific
interchange we're hopeful that the
completion of the project in mid-2024
will greatly improve all traffic flows
throughout the northwest corridor
obviously that doesn't do much for you
today mom but i'll pass your concerns
about the frustrated illegal turns along
to the nevada highway patrol
thanks for riding in buckle up drive
carefully please put on that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8 news now dot com